this chapter is kind of an interesting
one because lumping together a couple
different developments and movements you
notice it talks about liberalism in
religion we've talked about quite a few
liberal denominations with respect to
Christianity and even with respect to
Judaism but now it's talking about
liberal religion in America as such and
it's going to bring in a few other
players into this the radicalism part
really I don't know why you put that at
the chapter because it doesn't it
doesn't fit the theme that well you
might say how America became a primarily
secular nation that's what this chapter
is really about so it's kind of doing
two things telling you about these these
very liberal groups organizations
movements and that's also talking about
why it is that say for example most
Americans actually don't know that much
about religion whereas if it were 40
years ago they probably wouldn't know
more about at least some varieties of
American religion so starts off by
talking about utility Rios not until
theories unitarianism sorry
utilitarianism as an ethics theory that
we go over unitarianism is a religious
movement that comes out of the
Congregationalists and we've already
charted out that at a couple different
points and it notes that in the 19th
century it's the farthest institutional
base for liberal religion was
unitarianism and remember what were the
Unitarians known for well rejecting the
Trinity you know focusing on the
individual and their own progress and
their self development saying that you
don't need any sort of Creed's or or
things like that they also tend to be
pretty pretty elite you know when they
merged with the Universalist they
brought in some of the
middle or middle class people but it
says that the family leadership
challenge from a number of different
directions and these different
directions are what we want to look at
in this chapter so one thing is
agnosticism we're going to hit on that
agnosticism was something fairly new on
the scene it had been around but it
hadn't been named for a long time a lot
of the ideas that unitarians had
developed were being adopted by other
Christian denominations under the
generic name of liberal Protestantism of
modernism you know like the benevolence
of God the potential of human happiness
contemporary Berlin the compatibility of
religious faith with contemporary
science and philosophy there was a
humanist movement we'll talk about what
humanism means in a minute and then the
depression came along and you know the
depression affected everybody's the
ability to get things done for
organizations so although they were our
class they they found themselves kind of
kind of shrinking a bit in what they are
able to do now in the 1950s and 60s you
see kind of a revival of unitarianism
and your book talks about why that was
the case they reorganize themselves
administratively they actually ended up
merging with the Universalists they sort
of renewed their commitment to
inclusiveness got got involved in for
example the civil rights struggle Reese
reasserted traditional social concerns
they started experimenting with new
forms of local structure and one of the
experiments that they did is what they
just your book talks about as the late
fellowship plan so unitarians were until
that time largely concentrated in New
England particularly at Massachusetts
particularly run Boston and actually
it's still the case that
this area has a lot more Unitarian say
that Colorado does or Wisconsin what
they did though is they took out
newspaper ads and they suggest that
people organize small informal group
meetings that in churches but in
people's houses or in rented structures
and that they would get together and you
know think about religion have a
dialogue do things like you know reading
texts playing music hearing people give
testimonies and this led to Unitarianism
spreading because some of these local
groups have actually turned into
congregations some of them remain you
know sort of low-level the then they
emerged in 1961 with the Universalist
Church forming this new denomination and
your book talks about some of the social
issues that they've been involved in so
when we again when we talk about
liberalism we're usually thinking about
people that are progressive people that
are trying to change society towards
their vision something that's more
inclusive more more affair breaking down
social barriers your book talks about a
number of important feminist leaders
susan b anthony you might know from
those only dollars that used to
circulate around the coins well worth
reading though she was a Unitarian quite
a few unitarians were involved in the
civil rights movement and then one of
the things that we saw in the 1970s and
80s was a lot of the forces that had
been sort of set in motion by the civil
rights movement channa do mainly with
african-americans in the south and then
with you know african-americans in the
northern cities and then the feminist
movement was other liberation movements
came about and unitarians were involved
in those championing gay rights for
example already in the nineteen
ATS your book talks about them as being
a small denomination that's the that is
quite true they don't plan to expand
they don't plan to try to take up a much
greater as we call it market share from
the religious marketplace instead they
view themselves as sort of an elite that
are evangelist not for the group itself
but rather for the causes of the spouses
demographically one of the really
interesting features of the Universalist
like your book points out is about
eighty percent of the membership came to
the association's for affiliation rather
than birth so what does that actually
mean if their numbers are staying more
or less constant and about twenty
percent of them were born into it you
know like a lot of people are born into
their parents religion you know most
most Catholics are not converts they
were baptized as infants as Catholics
same thing you could probably say for
foremost Baptists foremost Presbyterians
their parents kind of dictated that and
some of them you don't go off the
proverbial reservation and say I'm doing
something different but a lot of lot of
religions are associated with these
long-standing communities yeah I have
listed weird question
sure would like the Amish being
considered something like that or are
they more of just a society are they
like villages they don't make a lot of
the hundreds that's that's pretty I mean
most people who are Amish is because the
parents are Amish the grandparents are
Amish they you know they have that time
when they got to choose whether to
reaffirm that to integrate that into
their lives but the ones that did you
know there's not a lot of evangelist out
there saying hey let's make everybody
off with the Unitarians eighty percent
of them started out as not being
Unitarians so it's largely a church of
Congress their numbers are staying the
same so what else does that tell you
yeah well they are losing people but
they're getting other people back in
return it's kind of a revolving door
church or religious organization each
generation you know if you join and then
you know most of the people in the
organization once you're having kids are
not in there because their parents were
but because they were attracted to her
for one reason or another that means a
lot of the kids are actually leaving
otherwise they'd be growing right they'd
be growing back that leaves about so
that's something important to keep in
mind we're going to where do they go to
a lot of them sort of spin off into
other liberal denominations then your
group starts talking about some American
history and they go back to the
Revolutionary era we talk now about
unitarians
go a little bit further back and we've
mentioned that before you have the dates
and Babli were also Unitarian in the
sense that they didn't believe in the
Trinity they believed in God being a
creator who sort of sets up the world
they thought that Jesus was a nice guy
but but not God incarnate and they
thought that you could figure out what
God's plan was by looking at the natural
law which was revealed through science
and through morality so you know some
important examples this were thomas
jefferson but also toms pink Thomas
Paine wrote a book called the age of
reason which is which is quite
interesting he wrote it during the
French Revolution who is the french
revolution against what do you remember
from your history classes yeah well get
a way more boobies in that lee the 16
I'll do that if I do it yet you're right
what a lui but not just a king because
they you know they killed him but they
killed a lot of other people who is the
revolution targeting who are they saying
have been screwing everybody else over
common people for four centuries king
and the Queen anyone else remember yeah
yeah the aristocracy the nobility they
gotten rid of pretty much any one of
those that they could get their hands on
some of them got over the country and
survived but many of them found their
way to the the executioner the
guillotine was the you know designed to
make executions quicker and more humane
and it was put to great effect during
the French Revolution who else was it
against yeah yeah the Catholic Church
religious orders were in fact closed and
kicked out of France overnight and many
priests and nuns and monks were told you
know
you're no longer a religious and we
might just kill you now bless you the
French Revolution switched you know away
from Catholicism being the official
state religion to a lot of endorsement
of atheism Thomas Paine was was very
worried about that he thought that if
you go all the way to atheism then there
won't be any morals and everybody will
just you know do whatever they want he
thought that day ISM was going to be a
substitute for that so he wrote this
book the age of reason which is an
argument for Corday ISM now after the
Civil War these were people who are you
know engaging in a tax on traditional
religion after the Civil War like it
says the tax on traditional religion
played a small but important role in the
public realm of debate somebody they
match as you've probably read mark twain
Samuel Clemens was real name of Mark
Twain probably you haven't read books of
his that that directly attack or
satirize religion you know like Tom
Sawyer or Huck Finn there's some things
about you the creatures and that but he
wrote other books where he's you know
very explicitly targeting the religion
of his time and then something else
starts to come on the sea agnosticism
and when we use that word agnostic how
hard big Gnostics different nadeyus yeah
just from what I always thought it was
it was like you not really concerned
with whether or not there is a God
doesn't you're not out to prove that
there isn't or to find it you're just
kind of you know sort of you get you get
theism on the one hand you know belief
in god or gods now then you have atheism
on the other hand and agnosticism
middle media that's what I always
thought it was good you know it could be
it could be from a variety of different
standpoints we could be in da well look
we just can't know you know maybe the
atheists are right maybe the theater
right who knows could be I don't really
care it's not relevant to me doesn't
play the important role in my life that
was not something that was a very common
stance say during the Reformation
ordering the you know America before the
Civil War there were actually a lot of
people for whom religion didn't have a
lot of rap relevance particularly an
unchurched areas but as time went on
more and more people got drawn into the
disorder trees so this guy Hawksley he
claims his term agnosticism and like
your book points out it enters the
American vocabulary and people would
call themselves agnostics when they
thought that it's just not relevant to
my life or I just can't possibly know
and along with agnosticism tended to go
the view that really a lot of these
questions aren't to be handled by
religion there to be handled by say
philosophy or science or something else
maybe history so a lot of the big
questions that religion have been
answering for a lot of people we're
getting displaced to other disciplines
your book also talks about Mencken if
you've never read HL Mencken I strongly
suggest that you read at least some of
this stuff he's he's an extremely funny
guy so if you're religious you probably
will be offended in reading Mecca
because he also had a lot of bile for
religion he covered the Scopes Monkey
Trial and really just Hillary the
Conservatives there a few other things
that we're going on as society grew more
pluralistic that means there's more and
more
were being represented court decisions
begin to constrict the expression of
religious themes in public arenas why
well because you know if you well let's
think about you know some some
contemporary examples what are the
problems that people usually have with
Ten Commandment displays and say
courthouses know there's a big thing
going on right now because forget
exactly what the courthouse it is but
you know it's got a bunch of different
religious a statuary you call it and the
Satanists now have a statue that they
have been building and they're going to
put in there it's like circulating
around on the internet how do we get to
that point or what would be wrong for
for example with you know having like in
the town square having a Christmas
display not just like Santa Claus and
candy canes or Christmas trees but you
know Jesus and Joseph and Mary and the
wise men and that sort of thing at a
nativity scene why do people get it you
know leery about that does it bother any
of you if they do that sort of thing
it's fine their electric bill well times
good thing you want the recent case that
UMass report a prayer Wow feel as if
governments is condoning certain
religions purging
those who included feel like the talent
often taken serious yeah that's exactly
it if your do not represent it that it
feels like a what about what about me
don't I count am I a second-class
citizen how are these other people
looking at me too if I don't you know
fit in with what they're doing I don't
endorse it so you know the Supreme Court
engage in a lot of cases like this going
all the way back to the 1940s in some
cases it a really picked up speed in the
60s and 70s now this ended up producing
a backlash you know what the tax against
secular humanism I remember what I was a
kid so I'm talking about the 80s people
were very very worried about secular
humanism and how it was going to destroy
the youth and we had folks that we had
read about it you know turned out there
weren't that many secular in this out
there as many as we collect so this is a
good point to talk about humanism
humanism by the way is a term that
doesn't necessarily mean secular
humanism there were great humanists in
the Renaissance you know there's a whole
bunch of people that we just call the
humanists like Erasmus because a
correspondent to Martin Luther a lot of
what they did was sort of try to recover
ancient Greek and Latin philosophy to
some degree theology history literature
and to talk about the human condition
they wanted to focus on what makes us
human what is our experience what is
central to us how can we live better
lives and some of the more religious and
some of them were not with some of them
were actually you know when it comes
down to it atheists in recent times when
people start calling themselves
humanists quite often there's a
religious or at least non-religious you
know sort of aspect to it although there
are important Christian Jewish you know
humanists in the 20th century but the
least of people who are signing these
manifestos like the first humans
manifest on the second much more starkly
oppositional humanist manifesto a little
own the secular humanist manifesto they
are seeing it as a sort of taking
religion and taking all the religiosity
out trying to capture what religion
would give us without actually being
committed to any particular religion
your book points out a number of
different organizations that tend to be
allied with humanism one of the ones
that they talk about is ethical culture
not very big big in this area founded by
Felix Adler reform rabbi it stresses
human moral responsibility and potential
and it provides sort of an organized
forum for discussion and education for
families who aren't comfortable with
with traditional religion but other
groups that they mention would be like
the ACLU you know they often bring cases
to the Supreme Court they drink briefs
people for the American Way which was
founded by Norman Lear to try to
counteract the moral majority which
again was big thing in the nineteen
eighties kind of waned in the 1990s some
Jewish organizations that are that are
you know they don't like that the notion
that America would be a Christian nation
which is very you know tough sell these
days there's a few organizations of
atheists you know where you actually see
a lot of perfect in discussions about
atheism is not so much in organizations
that actually bring people together
face-to-face where do you see a lot of
this stuff instead what would be the
alternative
just type an atheist into google search
and there will be some organizations
that come but there'll be some of the
bad set come on you know atheists
getting together important people at
Richard Dawkins will come on but but
what else will come up or type an
atheist vs christian atheist vs creation
duster something like that get a lot of
YouTube lots of scientists yeah not
necessarily scientists and those who do
not believe scientific theories because
some of the ones on the cider I'm
actually scientists they're sort of
evangelists of science but there they
have the view that science can answer
and then you know the some other
opposition they try to sort of formulate
what they're doing is kind of a science
but pretty unsuccessfully but ed is
amiss as such you can find it is hun of
discussions on baton on the internet
there's like an entire sphere you know
there's there's people I hesitate to
bring up any one of them because it
sounds like I'm endorsing that as
opposed to other ones but there are some
people who have you know millions of
YouTube fathers who do videos about
atheists some of them quite angry some
of them bit more rational so let's move
out of it another thing of the book
talks about here here's one of the sort
of dilemmas that you have to face and
thinking about this from any sort of
religious studies perspective is there
really a kind of you know concerted
effort to push religion out of American
life to marginalize it to change the you
know we see that America has been a
variable
this nation for much of its history is
there some sort of a massive concerted
effort to do so or is this more a
product of you know social changes
cultural changes that we can look at
where you can't say ah those those
people are in charge and they're the
ones who are doing your book and I think
correctly takes the position that's more
the second and they talk about the
difference between secularism and
secularity secularity is the state of
you know religion not mattering to the
degree that it used to where religion
becomes privatized where religion
becomes in many respects pushed to the
margins Americans you know unfortunately
because of that software from a high
degree of religious theory not knowing
very important things about religion
because it's possible to know all about
religions without actually endorsing
them participating or appreciating them
and if you don't know much about
religion it's very hard to know much
about history or about a lot of
literature or why the world is the way
it is you know because religion has been
such an important force in history but
there's a lot of people for whom
religion just doesn't have much much
relevance what talks about this category
of the nuts but not nuns like wearing
habits nuns as in when you're when
you're asked to list your religious
affiliation they put none because they
never had any privilege or they never
saw any particular religious group as
having anything relevant to say to them
and you know as I point out the Pacific
Northwest in particular is a vast area
of nuns wear a large part of the
population if you ask them what's your
religious affiliation villas a line
hemet what would you what would you be
if you had to pick something well I
don't know never really thought about
there's other areas that cannot fit into
that as well and your book talks about
some sort of let's call it recent
ancient history that probably isn't
particularly relevant about you know the
death of God movement in the 1960s and
Harvey Cox the secular see all of that
is kind of in some respects beside the
point that was providing sort of an
intellectual justification for being gay
and none after a generation or so of
none ISM if you want to call it that a
really no substantive engagement with
religion people will you know are kind
of at sea with what would you even what
would even mean to be rude just I
remember meeting a you know I the group
of the Midwest yeah most people were
affiliated with some sort of religious
group when I was a kid and probably they
didn't practice too much of it a lot of
more hypocrites and you know both of us
who can't go to catechism or stuff like
that didn't learn it awful why but at
least it was a sense of you were this or
you that right and it mattered in some
sort of strange way I remember meeting a
graduate student from California I know
the first people I've met who genuinely
didn't you can sort of like a blank
stare whenever we talk about religious
issues this is down in the Bible Belt
what were I was going for a high school
and southern Illinois which was really
solid and he would you just couldn't get
it what he was one of these sort of
generational lumps and it was striking
to me to run into somebody like that but
that's a larger and larger popping up
part of our American population your
book also talks about something else
that's that's very interesting i'm
skipping over a bit of stuff here and
i'm actually put down the term that they
coin for this
she lies this guy Robert Bella he had
some some co-writers on this book the
habits of the heart he was a sociologist
he's the guy who came up with the you
know this big emphasis on civil religion
we're going to look at in the next
chapter 2 he found this this woman
Sheila and she was sort of emblematic of
an attitude towards religion that's
highly individualistic very eclectic we
might say you guys know what this term
eclectic means yeah even it like a lot
of different things yeah you know where
it usually comes up what kind of music
do you like I have eclectic tastes right
I like a little bit of this and we'll do
that this think of it like a you know
eclecticism going to the buffet as
opposed to ordering off the menu right
you get to pick whatever you like and
you know you know if you don't like this
thing don't pick that dish took another
dish so what your pledges don't fill up
your plate so I wish they had the quote
here from her because it's really quite
interesting here's here's how the books
authorizes it there is a swarm an inch
and she describes her name was she
lettered she described her religious
position as Sheila ism by this she meant
that she had no need for traditional
organized religious groups rather she
was content to fashion her own eclectic
individualistic system of beliefs for
herself she'd like to pick a little bit
of this all over those whatever it was
relevant for her at the time ensure she
ilysm is a vividly specific example of
religion in the modern world not
disappearing but becoming totally
detached from any sort of communal
tradition based really a sort of
community of belief and practice and
there's more and more people that are
that are like that a lot of people who
say I'm not I'm not religious but I'm
spiritual they probably would fit in
to this this you know phenomenological
description of sheila ism so you're the
chapter ends with this paradox american
society is at the same time more
religious and certain eyes because
people who are religious are a bit more
outspoken they stand out more and on the
other hand it's also a nation has become
much less religious at the same time and
it varies from place to place you know
where where are you finding religion
stronger in the more traditional areas
where are you going to find it weaker in
the places that are less traditional
where a lot of social change going on